here along Chad's border with Sudan
where one in three people is a refugee
stories of atrocities abound fresh from
a visit the chief prosecutor of the
international criminal court Kareem Khan
told the security Council he's gathered
evidence of war crimes and I can confirm
to the council that we are collecting a
very significant body of material
information and evidence that is
relevant to those particular crimes
over 600,000 Sudanese fled West R4 last
year as the fighting got worse even as
rapid support forces battled the
Sudanese Armed Forces for control in the
capital human rights groups have alleged
civilians were deliberately targeted and
killed in clashes with the rsf and
Allied militias the prosecutor says he's
found evidence of atrocities on all
sides of Sudan Civil War but has
received little cooperation from
authorities we have not received a scrap
of
paper from the Sudanese Armed
Forces I met with General
aloran in September and he
promised cooperation with the
IC but despite that promise to me face
to face we have received no information
whatsoever the ICC prosecutor has yet to
formally charge any individuals but he
has the authority to do so under a 2005
Security Council resolution and his most
recent comments suggest those charges
may be coming soon Kristen salumi Al
jazer the United
Nations make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer